in this panel discussion we have parents
of children using cannabis and they are
going to share their experience by using
cannabis with their children and their
activism in the cannabis space starting
with Hara Osbourne the mother of twins
with fragile X syndrome
she is a activist on many organizations
and the original co-founder of the
strains product line in initially
Colorado era good morning thank you very
much
so my story began five years ago when a
good friend of mine who had heard about
cannabis and how it was changing lives
like a second in Colorado for families
that had children that had seizure
disorders my girlfriend shared this
information with me along with some of
the products and family stories I was
hesitant because I grew up in a family
where cannabis was you didn't even
discuss it it was taboo so I tried using
it with my son just CED strictly CBD and
didn't really notice anything at first
high to up the dose and immediately when
we hit the proper dose we saw huge
improvements shortly after that my son
suffers like Kenneth said heard of
something called fragile x syndrome
which is the leading genetic cause of
autism his body he lives in something
called fight-or-flight mode which means
his body cannot relax
so for eight years of his life he didn't
sleep so unlike a lot of the parents
that I have met through this journey my
son is a user of something called RSO
Rick Simpson oil without it he wouldn't
sleep when we first tried it I was
absolutely terrified and it had been 14
14 nights that he hadn't expected in a
row we used a little tiny rice grain on
a banana
gave it to him I've sat under his nose
all night long making sure he was
breathing because he was able all asleep
so our journey has been absolutely
incredible because from that night on
our lives had changed so I am excited to
be on this panel today and look forward
to sharing a lot more with everyone
Thank You Hera next we have Sebastian
coat
he is Jagger's dad in the co-founder of
George's hope and the national education
director for flowering Hope Foundation
Sebastian yes hi things can appreciate
it happy to view a few guys here today
my story actually started off jagger
story is my little boy he has a very
rare form of mitochondrial disease
Carly's disease it's very rare and it's
progressive and there's no cure for his
disease so Jagger will actually put on
hospice in late 2011 and put on a ton of
medication to try to just make his way
as left for his life as comfortable as
possible in 2013
one day just watching TV shows a
documentary in weed on CNN and all the
sudden I say well this is very
interesting cannabis could this help
January possible so start doing some
research met with some other parents in
Georgia
we co-founded geo just hope at the end
of 2013 to try to pass medical cannabis
bill here in Georgia we were not able to
do that so in August of 2014
my wife Annette Jagger and I decided to
move to Colorado and become medical
refugees so we could try medical
cannabis for Jagger our hospice team
told us then it would be 50/50 chance
you would not survive the trip we were
not allowed to fly with Jagger because
we almost have an emergency landing once
so we are blacklisted from flying
commercial airplane so we drove to
Colorado it was a horrible Drive took us
six days and you stop every three hours
because Jagger was doing so bad you
stopped breathing we were running a
hotel coming down we made it to Colorado
we made it there and we get a medical
card almost right away and on August
20th 2014 we gave Jagger is very first
those of his hope medical cannabis CBD
CBD first kind of like Harris story with
study with CBD and we saw some very good
improvement right away mostly in his um
his behavior eye tracking recognizing us
smiling again
he hasn't smiled before that for
probably a couple years so I was a big
deal for us and we were in Colorado for
thirteen months we were able to add some
mochi and I vino it to to his regiment
play with the dose and now Jagger is
seven
he is three and a half years seven and a
half three and a half years pass is most
optimistic life expectancy from any
doctor as 95% of Lee's disease kid did
not make it past their fourth birthday
we are back in Georgia so Jagger is
doing as good as he's going to do is
tear on hospice still a terminal patient
but it's quality of life increased
dramatically because of cannabis we were
able to reduce his seizures from 10 to
15 a day rate a four-day we were able to
reduce his pain crisis with muscle we
get so tight you would be in a lot of
pain we were to reduce that by about 90
percent we're getting 100% of the
oxycontin and about 95% of the morphine
just by using THD so you
no great again it's not a cure for here
mister the terminal patient but great
result was very excited and very happy
about everything cannabis in doing for
Jagger and I'm looking forward to share
a bit more of that and the struggle
we're having also in Georgia to get the
product that we need so that's my story
era could you describe your experience
on how you got to the point of cannabis
so I'd say it's David syndrome which
leads him come he's nonverbal still in
diapers at 14 years old when he was six
months old he had his regular scheduled
immunization and shortly about 15
minutes afterwards he had still not
stopped crying
I took him home we dealt with high
fevers non-stop screaming and crying the
point where the needle - in was was
swollen and inflamed I ended up taking
him calling the doctor's office and
thinking that they had left the needle
in the arm and it's arm long the notes
to me I didn't know about the MMR shots
and the thimerosal at that time I don't
share that part of this story lightly
because I I believe that people should
responsibly immunize but at that stage I
didn't know that he was a carrier or
that he had fragile X syndrome so I
didn't know that he was predisposed we
ended up changing pediatricians he never
looked at me again he didn't make eye
contact when I would nurse him he
wouldn't latch on so from that day
forward things changed progressively
getting worse as he got older we did
early intervention we never
experience these impact of the change as
we didn't plan of us we were involved in
several research studying studies that
involved you know cycling and several
other pharmaceutical drugs and just it
never worked well for our son
unfortunately from the day the very
first day that we tried Rick Simpson oil
we had great success
my son would sleep all night he would
wake up available to learn the next day
his behaviors were getting better and
self-injurious behaviors were getting
better and I mean it absolutely changed
every aspect of his sleep patterns the
CBD in conjunction helps my son with his
seizure activity
so about reduced greatly it has cannabis
has changed our lives and then instead
we were at a point that you know we
would have to go to California to
purchase it come back to Nevada where we
live and we we thought you know we don't
know who's making it and they were the
consistency was was sporadic and so we
thought you know we wanted to do this as
parents responsibly we wanted to provide
an option for other families to be able
to access medication that really worked
for their children we saw how it changed
our lives so you know here we are accord
and half years later providing medicine
to some of our grandmas that we had
shared our stories with and were were
building we're building different walls
we're building walls around families
where they feel protected that their
children can take cannabis because the
government walls that have been built
around our perception of what cannabis
is really about are so wrong and they're
crumbling down
and thinking this for other parents you
know such as myself that are able to
share their stories you know Sebastian
sharing his story with his son having
their quality of life there are so many
other people out there that have similar
stories that are afraid to say anything
about it because they don't want to be
judged or blackballed from the community
so doing this responsibly is so
important and you know admitting out
loud that you know our children take
cannabis and the highest forms of THC
cannabis it's dairy but when they see
the difference and the quality of life
when a child can go to a playground and
play or when a child can sleep all night
long and enjoy the luxuries of waking up
and not being exhausted we have to speak
loud so that's why I'm on the panel
today Sebastian what else would you like
to share well I think kind of like Hera
say it's a little bit scary when you
first come out and well first of all
when you first use medical cannabis for
your kid because there's such a stigma
for so many years when it's something so
bad when you actually worry a little bit
are you gonna hurt your kid are you
gonna make things worse our situation
being in on Hospice we didn't have
really a lot to lose right at the end of
the day we had to try something we had
to try something with with jagger it was
on you know oxycontin morphine valium
methadone you ever painting back of him
crazy amount of meds unlimited amounts
because when you're on a hospice it's
all about stopping the pain or stopping
the suffering and if you end up
overdosing in the meantime then so be it
so it's a sad reality of hospice care
but it's true so it was definitely a
little bit scary but we felt like it was
the right thing to do we didn't make
this decision just like this very
quickly once we did not pass a medical
cannabis bill in 2014 early 2014 in
Georgia I actually took a week vacation
from my job and I went to Colorado for a
week and I met with doctors
parents with growers when two
dispensaries and I really try to get the
most information I could to make the
best decision and within just a couple
days of being in Colorado
I just knew that's what we had to do for
jaga I didn't know how we were gonna do
it but I knew we had to do it and I went
home talked to my wife she was on board
right away and you know we put
everything in place we had to transfer
the hospice care to Denver we have to
get the doctor on board somewhere not on
board but we say we gotta do this we're
gonna move to Colorado so I was you know
it's not easy becoming a medical
refugees definitely one of the most
challenging thing you can do is you
leaving no only your family behind your
friend you support system your church if
you have it if you have a church you
doctor team Kimber took care of Jagger
sense first time you get in the hospital
when he was three months old
almost people know him really well his
doctor team we had to leave everybody to
get to Colorado so I was very scary and
then on top of that there's a financial
aspect Gerardo is very expensive it's
not easy
Corrado is more no expensive now as more
and more people are going there and
becoming medical refugee so you know
it's a very long journey it's a very
hard journey but it's absolutely worth
it 100% I would do it again if I had to
the only reason we get back to Georgia
was because Jagger was doing much much
better with everything
seizures of pain their awarness as a
happiness the only problem with Colorado
for us was the attitude Jen I never got
used to the attitude and because Lee's
disease has a base it's a respiratory
base disease you know this lesion is the
basal ganglia they eventually moved on
to the brain stem which is the part of
the brain that control the breathing so
most kids with Lee disease end up
passing from respiratory failure
and we try for year we adjusted its
buyback registries oxygen we really try
to give you time to adjust these loans
just never adjust it so there is a
reason why we moved back to Georgia and
I was very challenging too because here
in Georgia now we do not have access to
cannabis we have a legal right to a
possession of it but we cannot legally
buy it there's nowhere to buy in the
state of Georgia and this
why we're fighting with Georgia's open
other groups to try to get that change
but for Jagger we just have to come back
to the breathing but we do miss Colorado
we miss the freedom we had in Colorado
we miss the options we had in Colorado
but you know cannabis is still keeping
jagger alive it's much more challenging
to get it but you know as a dad of a
sick parent as a dad of a sick child
sorry
you do what you got to do for your kid
so you know that's what we're doing and
now we trying to make jago's a few
months yours
Vanya's left we first the best possible
how has the medical community in Georgia
embraced the use of cannabis in how are
you acquiring the necessary medication
for Jagger so how am I worrying I'm
probably have to play the fifth on that
one
let's just put like this somehow it gets
here I wanted to hear it's it's legal
because we have a medical card so we
have legal possession of up to five
percent THC oil we do have a leave it on
th D in Georgia but obviously it's
illegal to get a here but once it's here
we have it so we get it here we find a
way we get it here and once we have it
here we legal the medical community that
is very interesting because at first I
remember when we started in 2013 they
were not in favor of it other maybe even
is auspice nurse because she say you
know anything I can help we forgetting
so much Oh kids when I'm fight
everybody else in urology is Moroccan a
disease doctor
everybody was just kind of like Kennedys
no we need more research we don't know a
lot about cannabis we you know maybe
there's a lot of side effects and my
answer was possibly but I can promise
you the side effects but it'd be a lot
less than the morphine you're giving him
the oxycontin you're giving him and at
the end of the day if you make him feel
better
um I'm gonna try it and I don't care
about side effects with Jagger you know
I'm being honest it makes things very
different you don't worry about what
could happen in two or three years from
now you're worrying about today and
tomorrow so what happened with George
a lot of parents like Hera was saying
share the story and a lot of parents
came out and sure that the capital went
to the media and we really started this
movement and we shared a story and we
had kids that in seizures on the floor
of the State Capitol and that make
people change your mind too a Saturday
is and moshing of the story all the
sudden you know people were using CBD
and THC then make the combination of
things and the doctor was saying that it
was working he was working better and
slowly but surely the medical community
has time to embrace this and as of today
we still have a long way to go but we do
have doctors willing to learn doctor
willing to hear the story we have doctor
signing for the cards we had 4,000
people on the registry and every one of
them I actually have a doctor sign up
for the card and we're doing
presentation and talk just a few months
ago we did talk at Emory hospital in
Atlanta I went 75 medical professionals
show up to listen to the cannabis 101
basic training just to know what is CBD
wise THC is very basic we had 75 medical
professionals showing outputs - sound
like a big number before Georgia the
deep south it's a huge number and slowly
but surely we're getting people to
change their mind and we get any doctor
to come on board and the kids honestly
the kid is what makes a difference
change the story it was doctor seeing
how cannabis can help the kids has made
all the difference in the world that's
that's tremendous info sebastian hara
what challenges have you run up against
with your twins and maybe you want to
mention a little bit about how your
daughter is found success with using CBD
absolutely the biggest challenge with
focusing on my son for a moment the
biggest challenge that I have found was
consistency as we were ramping up
giving applications in and being able to
make the products that can even know the
consistency it's an agriculture-based
you know medication so making sure that
you have a consistent product that time
and time again when utilized is it's
going to work
so the CVD never never a problem the
Rick Simpson oil we found challenges
with unfortunately so we are always
looking because as we all know every day
this industry is getting better
offering more products so I think that
that's been the biggest challenge
outside of you know people the
medication itself
my daughter has got a diagnosis
manifests itself in quite a different
way like I said this is fragile act so
females have two X chromosomes so she
has full mutation fragile s but
fortunately she's fairly high
functioning even though she has the full
mutation it manifests itself in being
very shy being very literal having very
very high anxiety not behaviorally but
you know within herself so CBD has been
the biggest blessing for her because any
event that she has to go to she knows
now at 14 years old when we're going to
take a dropper of CBD and I'm going to
feel better on my personality and I'm
going to be able to go in and take care
of it us so that's a very very exciting
it's that you know quite quite a
contrast in comparison to her brother
who can't even access his environment on
its own like I said he's still in
diapers nonverbal he he can't feed
himself he can't give him get himself a
drink he can't do anything so the Rick
Simms
oil really helps in conjunction with the
CBD for him to be able to have
combination skills and talk to us on his
operative technology to be able to
access his environment so even though
we've had the challenges with
consistency this by car has been the
best fit for his needs so when we in my
opinion thank you so much for that
wonderful information I'd like to turn
the conversation now to Janie Kneedler
the mother of right Riley and the
co-founder of Riley's smile foundation
in Riley's foundation nonprofit Jamie hi
there so Riley was diagnosed with bone
tumors when she was only 7 and the bone
tumors ate away her palate her maxilla
her cheek in the bottom of her eye orbit
and it was extremely aggressive so when
they went in and had to remove the tumor
they essentially removed about between a
third and a quarter of her bone
structure of her face and at the time
there was not a chemo that would really
help get rid of this tumor keep it the
high recurrence rate down enough so of
course as a mom you do all kinds of
research to save your baby and so
cannabis kept coming up and in our state
it was only legal for adult was not
legal for Pediatrics but you know that's
not gonna stop a mom on a mission and we
were able to find safe access to safe as
in it was from a dispensary um that was
you know had lab testing not safe as in
legal but we were able to acquire it to
have it sent to us and I was able to use
that for us we started seeing benefits
as in pain management immediately and
with the inflammation
and as far as benefits in her tumor and
the bone structure we started seeing
those benefits within six months and so
it's been four years she's considered
stable we're able to do her scans neck
now in one year and she's still getting
followed with regular tans and she does
still have you know so a little bit of
damage but on the outside when you look
at her she's absolutely gorgeous and
amazing and they fully expected her to
have you know some reconstructive
surgery and so as a side-effect I call
it a side-effect because this is not the
my original intention of giving her
cannabis but a side-effect was that she
had amazing bone regeneration and bone
growth from the cannabis and you expect
this to happen with such a young child
anyway but the the beautiful
regeneration that she had was was
definitely unexpected
how complete it was and and how healthy
it was and strong it was so she she did
also develop seizures after her
debulking surgery this is exactly almost
two weeks from her debulking surgery
which was a full day surgery and I don't
know if it would have happened anyway
because of the trauma that she went
through but so the cannabis does help
control her seizures she's on a very
very low dose of lamictal and she's on
CBD THC a a very small amount of THC she
uses it sublingually she uses sprays
nasal sprays because that's a wonderful
delivery method and she also uses
topical creams on her face for her pain
and that sort of thing that's a
tremendous story what was the response
coming from the doctors that were
working with your daughter what was
their response to the incorporation of
cannabis and the ultimate outcome that
you're seeing
so the her tumor team really didn't want
to make a lot of comment because their
Hospital policy is is not for cannabis
they had to be very careful about what
they said I I do know that they were
very happy that she was fine being pain
relief their response as far as her her
healing and the bone regeneration was
very positive and every time they saw
her they would just shake their heads
about how wonderful she looked and and
how kind of miraculous the bones were
regenerating so beautifully and how
great she looked when we took her for a
second opinion to Johns Hopkins that
doctor I believe was catching on to what
we were doing he asked me you know what
are you giving her and he said I can't
even tell by looking at her medical
history looking at what's been done to
her and then seeing her in front of me I
cannot tell that she's had what she's
had done to her and he said it's just
amazing and whatever you're doing keep
doing it and so we were using the terms
essential oils because it was still
illegal and Maryland where this doctor
was and it was also illegal in Delaware
so we had a lot of people noticing that
she was having these wonderful results
but because of the legality of it we had
to be very careful with wording of what
we were using and you know every time we
walked out of the doctor's office I was
making mental notes I was writing down
what they were saying because they would
just look at her and step back and all
look at each other and just shake their
heads and say we didn't expect that we
you know her healing you just can't tell
this child has been through what she's
been through and you would actually have
to look at her medical records to prove
that what we're seeing in front of us
has had this happen to her did you
suggest to the physicians that were so
amazed to consider this as a case study
and publish it so we have talked to a
few doctors about that we actually had a
doctor in Israel asked us when I showed
him her records he he just bluntly said
to me have you had a case study done on
this child and I said well we have
mentioned it to a few doctors who
treated her but they fear for their job
so we're and and the the people that
they work for it's they're walking a
very fine line so they have to be very
careful of you know promoting to use
this for this type of tumor you know
it's very new in our state and the
medical community is is not really for
it just yet they're very on the fence
and and to put it you know bluntly we
live in a i dupont state and AI DuPont
is is really on the fence about it and
so that is our struggle right now is to
is to educate the medical community
which is one of the reasons I was so
excited to do this panel and and I also
travel around and speak to medical
professionals is we're trying to you
know open up those doors and get them to
look more into it and to see these
patients and see what's happening to
these children in a positive light and
not to be as concerned about you know
the potential downside of it harming her
intellectually you know she has straight
A's
and she's been doing very well in school
and
one time that we tried to we tried to
titrate down in her cannabis oil because
we thought hey we got the results we
wanted so why should we keep her on it
so we tried to titrate down and that's
when we discovered how bad her seizures
were actually were and that's when we
discovered you know how how bad without
it her pain and her facial area really
was and her grades just plummeted her
her teachers were calling me and saying
that they were concerned about her
because she was just so you know her she
was so Spacey and I think the pain was
taking so much energy from her and
physically that she couldn't concentrate
and and you know and in my mind I I feel
that you know I can to give cannabis the
credit for her the grades that she has
that's just a tremendous story can you
share with us the kind of dosing the
Riley needs so now remember she takes it
sublingually and so we're actually
working right now with you know I just
got back from Israel and that's one that
was one of the top subjects that was
discussed in Israel that I find very
interesting and so about bioavailability
and so we're actually investigating a
way to get the cannabinoids into her at
different routes because she does take
it sublingually and she is needing to
take about 200 to 230 milligrams of
whole plant CBD a day now this CBD has
about 6 or 7 percent THC in it so it's
it's not the same percentages as like
Charlotte's Web or other hemp products
it's a little it's more like an ac/dc
kind of percentage so that is a to me a
lot of milligrams and if you know the
of cannabis it's expensive too now the
the THC a she's taken about 45 to 50
milligrams a day and it's all of us has
split up into you know four doses a day
because it's not time released when she
needs that the nasal spray the THC nasal
spray it's usually when we're traveling
when she's had you know dental work when
she's a high stress you know because she
might clinch a little bit it's it's
usually because of the bone pain so
that's a nasal spray and it works very
differently only you don't need as much
because of the way that that it absorbs
so what I'm looking at what and who I
was talking to a lot in Israel were the
manufacturers and the doctors who were
inventing you know inhalers they were
inventing you know sublingual mouth
sprays that would that with spray into
the mouth and absorb in that way or even
nasal sprays because you can actually
take a much much lower dose and your
body is not filtering it out it's not
wasting it because a lot of times we
need to take a sublingually you know up
to 90% of it is waste it right out so
you know not only is it raise your body
using it better but you're not wasting
money you're not wasting plant material
so that's kind of our next step is to
find her a better delivery method that
is wonderful very helpful information
bioavailability and route of
administration really is critically
important and you know for people taking
tinctures or solutions tinctures being
alcohol-based solutions being oil-based
or some other carrier delivering the
actives it most children cannot hold
something in their mouth for five to 15
minutes
and so my availability right orally goes
down substantially when that medication
is a isn't absorbed through the oral
mucosa Sebastian can you share with us
the dosing that you're using with Jagger
yeah absolutely
so Jagger is taking CBD THC and CBN the
dosing we're using right now we work our
way up to bat those we obviously started
very low and increases as needed Jagger
right now is taking about 65 milligrams
of CBD a day about 70 75 milligrams of
THC a day and about 12 to 15 min ago M
of CBN a day with those CBD three times
a day with those THC in the morning in
the afternoon and with those CBN a night
the issue with Jagger and we have is the
fact that E has aspiration so we cannot
have anything by mouth Jagger is 100% a
tube said GJ tube so we do lose some of
our bioavailability to keep up the same
topic because we have to put in his
feeding tube we do have some spray we do
have the nasal sprays a seminal spray
that Janie has per Riley we do have a
mouth spray but we use was just really
as more as rescue medication for him
even just the sublingual the mouth spray
could be an issue if we give too many
spray either be choking and you know
because of the aspiration so we do have
a bioavailability issue we are aware of
that as jagged disease is progressing we
also seeing a lot of motility issues and
absorption issue so that is a big
challenge for us we are trying to be
inventive we did try and at time use
rectal delivery I get a little tricky
I'm not exactly sure if it works really
well for Jagger or if you works really
well
you know as a whole but yeah the
bioavailability and the absorption issue
and the fact is NPO or nothing by mouth
that make you a challenge for Jagger so
we are looking at different option one
thing I just heard of a mom trying and
that's how we you know we rely on other
parents to a lot and other people's
advice have a mom saying that a kid when
you're having really bad pain crisis she
takes a little bit of concentrate and
put it into the belly button and
actually about social value any seems to
help our kid I'm not try that with
Jagger yet but that's always you know
we're always looking for different
things and different thing that can help
us especially with these issues thank
you so much for sharing that information
Hira can you share with us the dosing
that you're using with your children so
my daughter just recently started taking
trophies and so she takes a quarter of a
trophy in the morning and then takes
another order of a trochee in the
afternoon so right now my son we have
increased his RSO to afternoon a little
bit in the afternoon when he starts to
get agitated because I'm trying to wean
him off his risperidone but he gets
again he's starting the picture he's
along with strains tinctures and so he
gets to MLS in the morning and then he
gets a quarter a trophy in the afternoon
and there's really there's no fine
dosing per se for the RSO because it's
delivered in a syringe and so it's again
the the exact Josey of a rice grain or a
pea size depending on the time the day
what trokey are you using CBD only the
CBD
and then sometimes if my if my son is
still having a hard time sleeping I'll
get him TV with melatonin I have about
eight o'clock at night just to try to
calm his body a little bit so for the
audience that's trokey CBDs or fifty
milligrams and a quarter of a joke II
would be 12 and a half milligrams of CBD
in that route of the administration and
delivery system I think it's really good
that we're having this panel to remind
medical professionals that this isn't
about the the bubble of you know the
green rush that this is really supposed
to be about the patient and their
experience in their quality of life and
but but I do think it's important for
somebody to bring up that this is a
cannabis is not a magic bullet and and
you know I knew Sebastian knows that I
mean for our family it was almost a
magic bullet yes it brought her into
remission but it's not gonna it didn't
cure her her pain but it did bring her
quality of life that she can be a normal
child she can go to a sleepover and not
have a seizure or not be crying in pain
and have to come home from that you know
happy in at a friend's house or having
the friend's mom call me and freak out
and say I don't know what to do she's
she's on the floor you know in pain but
there's a lot of cases like Sebastian's
that this is not the Magic Bullet but
quality of life is the big thing so I
think that's important for parents to
know that they're not just going to give
their child cannabis and everything's
going to be a hundred percent okay that
is 100 percent dead-on so you know
sometimes I think that's medical
professionals they seem to the ones that
are a little bit doubtful they seem to
fall back on that and I've had that
happen to us where we when we gave
you know we we have peace since that
look ends no it didn't cure their
seizures a hundred percent but it did
make them you know it may gave them
instead of having three hundred seizures
maybe they had thirty and then the
doctor came back and said oh well it
didn't work you know what I mean and so
sometimes the physician against it will
fall back on that that it's not a magic
bullet to you know to say oh well it
doesn't work you know what I mean and
they're not absolutely and that is
something that I see in the functional
medicine arena where we're using
sometimes combinations of natural
products along with lifestyle choice
changes that have a significant impact
on this patient's disease or
symptomatology and you know because
there isn't a double-blind
placebo-controlled trial they discount
it right which is just I I think it's
ignorant and negligent on the part of
the physician because you know they had
the crowd at Goethe you know do no harm
and many of them do harm by preventing
the access the support the guidance of
what is now found in the literature the
literature there's a number of studies
published in March of this year that are
profound as far as guidance you know we
we I'm not sure how many medical schools
have a cannabis curriculum included I
know that UCSF my alma mater has had one
for quite a long time but you know at
one point in the last couple years there
was only ten medical schools that's just
that's just the crime
again we have to figure out a way to
hold our elected representatives
accountable for the failure of their
primary job which is to listen to the
people are our will and don't harm and
hurt us you know policy should be based
especially surrounding medicine on
science and that has never been the case
since the 1937 tax the the marihuana Tax
Act was put into place it was never
based on science exactly that was in
speaking of the double-blind placebo
that was one of the things that was
discussed from the platform in Israel
you know professor Augier ROM he's doing
the study on autism and he said that was
one of his problems with his study is
because when you're researching cannabis
with a double-blind placebo it's only a
matter of like a week or two before
their parents know that they're getting
a placebo because you you just know and
and because you don't have that
entourage effect you don't you don't
have any type of quality of life
benefits because you you see other
patients who aren't and that's it's very
hard to hide the placebos into the study
because there's such a drastic
difference in in the real medicine in
the placebo and he was telling us that
you know he was having parents come to
him on the side that you know can you
please switch my child and he was
begging he was telling them but but you
know please this look this is way it has
to be to make it worth it we have to
have a double-blind placebo to get the
government to listen to us and just like
you were saying that it has to be done a
certain way and you know some of us have
to suffer along though
but that's the way it has to be to get
the proper studies to show them that
this is real medicine and that there is
a difference it's not just in our heads
it's you know we're not it's we're not
having a placebo effect
study design can help address some of
that yeah right when there is a
substantial change in the the subjects
quality of life or symptomatology there
should be a point in time where that is
then documented and then in a crossover
design meaning each patient in the study
will have the same condition at some
point or the other even though it's
double-blind in randomized that then
once those symptoms come to a point of
patient risk you know going back to 300
seizures a day versus 30 seizures a day
or one seizure a day you know there's a
point in which still bona fide rock
solid science can can work within that
framework and still document and publish
valuable information which guides
medical treatment forward with the use
of cannabis right the bastion did you
have any other comments that you'd like
to add no it's very true and even if
you're looking at you know this is not
really related to pediatrics but more to
related to do a double-blind placebo FDA
study if you don't get sue Sisley and
her work with PTSD and the veterans then
she had to get kennedy's from NIDA the
National Institute of drug abuse you
know University of Mississippi because
seven years to get it once she got it I
have to study was with her in Scottsdale
Arizona half with John Hopkins
University they tested the cannabis and
he had more than it so John Hopkins
dropout
study so she waited seven years to get
federal government cannabis the only
legal way to get Kennedy's to do
fda-approved double-blind placebo
studying in the US and the cannabis is
absolutely junk
she can't even use it and our
frustration was I can go to California I
can go to Colorado walk in the street
corner to a dispensary at very good
quality cannabis do my study and move on
and I think get it done right away I
have my soup like tomorrow morning but
now I waited seven years so a lot of
this time we here I'll do a lot of
lobbying in Washington DC we need more
research in more research we FDA
research but the problem is then we can
get FDA research most of the time
because we still have was restriction
and he has to come from NIDA and that
cannabis is just horrible so it's kind
of one of those catch-22 situation where
we know it works we see with our kids we
see with other people kids we see with
all of her friends with patients you see
as a medical professional we all know
when it works but for the government and
for the people in charge of making
policies that affect our everyday life
they want my research we will run fda
research and my FDA research is not
possible because they're actually
blocking it the same people that are
asking us for our research are the same
people blocking blocking us from getting
very search so that's so that's that's a
big issue we have right now to get this
moving forward I I feel your pain and
there is no easy solution I am working
with the University of California Irvine
Center for the Study of cannabis and we
are trying to figure out how we can use
real world cannabis not NIDA cannabis
and still provide quality research using
something that actually is what is
actually being used no one uses the
quality of product that night is
providing at least in the United States
that that we know of
permitted States and the testing that we
see from those products that are
currently on the marketplace there's no
comparison and it is a crime that there
is at least 20 applications for
university based cannabis cultivation
sitting on the do J's desk and they're
not approving what was already
recommended to address the failure of
naida's responsibility by the
government's you know the definition of
what they're supposed to be providing I
mean they're failing miserable at it
when yeah I really hope that you know
what worked about this panel once want
some medical professionals even some
governmental agencies I'm hoping that
once they once they see it you know I
hope I'm hoping that it plants and seeds
it's them moving causes some action we
definitely need it they need to look at
the data that is currently in the
literature in recognize even the you
know be the report that came out in
January of last year from the National
Academy of Sciences engineering and
medicine which unequivocally identified
cannabis as being helpful in three
different conditions
one being chronic pain and adults we're
faced with an opiate epidemic and we
have a product that won't suppress
respiration won't make an opiate more
dangerous like the other medications
that are included with opiates and it's
still not part of any dialogue both at
the National
Institute of Health Initiative or in the
executive office of trumps
administration well I would like to
thank our panel for sharing this wealth
of information different parts of the
country different conditions different
dosing different it for the families out
there with children and I I run across
this regularly even in California at our
clinic there's there's just not a lot of
support in the medical community
recognizing that California has had
medical cannabis the longest in the
country and in most referrals come from
family and friends to individuals that
don't know a thing about it and think
that it's a gateway drug and here the
misinformation in the news media and the
lack of information because from their
physicians because their physicians are
both afraid of losing their their
license from the local medical boards
their DEA registration from the federal
government today still if a prescriber
with a DEA number talks to a patient
about how to use and what to use
cannabis for that is essentially aiding
and abetting a felony this has got to
change
and with the activate the activism that
you all are doing in your states and
with the ability to share your story
which is so profound
and documenting to the world in to our
federal government in the u.s. that
there is medical indications for
cannabis or in their mind marijuana you
know and that the continued oppression
of cannabis by leaving it as a Schedule
one drug
meaning there is no recognized medical
value is harming our citizens our
children everyone that could benefit
from this powerful adaptogenic earth so
thank you all